All right.
So we know something about all of these
powerful tools that have been developed,
quantum mechanics around the
turn around 1925 26 actually.
And then all these much more modern things
including scanning probe microscopy,
which is really quite recent,
but the most powerful tool in organic
chemistry for everyday practice.
And certainly for anybody who's not a
professional chemist then into the quantum
mechanics and stuff like that is bonds,
this amazing invention of bonds and how
people knew what things were like before
any of these tools were dreamt
of. Right? And for that,
we go back in time and look at these
guys in the 19th century who invented it
and we begin with what's called, whoops,
we begin with, sorry, here we go again.
Okay. We begin with the
chemical revolution, right?
That's a name that historians of science
have given this period beginning with
Lavoie Ca.
So really that's where we'll start.
But he didn't just spring from nowhere.
There was a long tradition of some
kinds of chemistry before that.
And we're going to just
review that very briefly.
There's a background in
ancient art and lore.
Okay. So, for example,
here's a mosaic from
Moriali and Cecily of Noah,
right as a making wine and then falling
victim to it and having his shame hidden
by his sons. Okay. And
here's his flask, right?
So Kevin, this is like, you know,
uh, 3000 years ago, the, the,
the uh, mosaic is about a thousand years.
Let's 12th century. It's 800, nine, eight,
900 years old,
okay.
Here is a Roman glass perfume
bile that's 2000 years old.
So they made perfume obviously
and extracted the stuff
from flowers and whatever
that would, that would do, do that. Hey,
there's the chemical research building
when it was five days old. Okay.
And we already saw Francis Bacon who
said all the philosophy of nature,
which has now received is either the
philosophy of the Grecians or that of the
alchemists. So the alchemists
are in a sense, our ancestors,
he didn't have very high opinion of them.
He said the one is gathered out
of a few vulgar observation.
That's the Greek philosophers.
And the other out of a few
experiments have a furnace, right?
The one never fail is to multiply words.
And the other ever fail us.
The multiply gold.
So even at this time when science
was beginning to get underway,
modern science alchemy
was already in disrepute,
but it w but it did
contribute some things.
It didn't contribute much to theory
because the theory dependent on,
on a Greek,
well on the Greek antecedents and the
authority rather than observation.
But they did fiddle around,
here's a painting of
an alchemist from 1663.
And Remember Newton did more work
in alchemy than he did in physics,
right? And he wrote an enormous amount,
but never published anything about it.
There's a great,
there's a great website now from the
University of Indiana of all Newton's out
chemical works and you can look at them.
Uh,
but this was to be kept a secret.
That was the idea of Alchemy,
right? That it was a
cult. It was hidden. Okay.
And in fact,
there's a show that's coming up at,
on Alchemy at the Beinecke Library of
there in January of their holdings in
alchemy. And the title of the show
is the book of secrets, right?
And that's Harry Potter as well,
right?
So here's one of the things
that's going to be shown.
It's part of a really long scroll,
which is the Vizio Mystica of Arnold,
of Villanova for who was a 13th century,
uh,
outcomist who was into medicine,
was considered the greatest
medical authority of its time.
This particular scroll was
written in England in 1570.
So a lot of it's in English.
It says the Red Sea,
the Red Loon, the red moon,
the red sole, the Red Sun,
right? All sorts of mystical things.
And then you see, here's the here,
here is that the Corpus,
the body, which is earth.
And here's the soul,
which is oil.
And here's this spirit or the
air, the breath, which is water.
So there was everything was
a symbol for something else.
Or if you look at the four corners
of this on the bottom right,
we have air right air,
it says is hot and moist,
right?
Or in the top left is earth,
which is cold and dry.
The opposite of air.
And down here is fire,
which is hot and dry and up.
And there is water,
which is, uh, which is
cold. And Moist, right?
So this was supposed to be
something profound and mysterious.
Another thing they're going to show is
this book on the philosopher's stone,
which was written in the 13th century.
The particular copy they have is from
1571 but it looks like somebody organic
chemistry text after they've highlighted
it in preparation for the exam,
every word is underlined,
right?
And all in the margin or these
fingers pointed two important things,
right? Uh, and if you look there,
you'll see great words like alchemy.
There you see Elixir.
Uh,
I forget there are a lot of key words,
but fundamentally it's all nonsense,
all the theory.
The reason people kept it
secret really was I think,
not to keep other people
from finding it out,
but to hide the fact that it was nonsense.
That that's just my own theory. So
maybe that's wrong. Okay. But that,
but the Paracelsus in the early 15
hundreds was an alchemist that visit
traveling physician and he developed
what had been long before that,
which was the doctrine of sympathies.
And that one aspect of that was in nature,
antidotes for poisons are to be
found near the source of the illness,
right? So for example,
you know what that is?
Yeah,
Poison Ivy, right? But near Poison Ivy,
you're likely to find jewel weed,
which is an antidote for poison ivy,
right?
Or that poison ivy is a new world thing.
So that didn't interest the alchemist.
But this one certainly did.
Willow Salix is the Latin name for willow,
which is found in malarial swamps. So
you go into a swamp, you get malaria,
but you also find the willow there and
the willow bark extracting from the
willow bark.
You can get salads in a glycoside,
which is a sugar plus
aromatic thing there. Right?
And if you hydrolyze that to get the
sugar off and oxidize that to make a
carboxylic acid,
you get this.
What's that? Right?
Salycilic acid from sailings.
Right. So it's good for fevers
and so on for your malaria. Okay,
so that's the theory.
This is another thing,
they're going to show a video
and make them come along with me,
which is a lab manual that was kept by
cos bar Hartung from Hoff in 1557 in
Austria. So you can see as he
draws various app what he's,
he's reading various things,
right?
And writing extracts and
notes to himself about,
it's like your prelab
preparation, right? Uh, okay.
And you notice how he's quoting up here,
Arnold, that guy from the 13th century
who did the thing we've showed first,
right? Arnold of a Villanova. Okay.
But he shows distillation apparatus.
These things are called Pelicans.
That interesting.
Uh,
and here's a lamp and here is somebody,
he's filtering something through some
kind of screen or grid there. Okay.
So they developed tools,
right?
That were great use to
chemistry once chemistry,
chemistry got going. So there was a lot
of, even though the theory was nonsense,
there was a lot of practical background
in preparing various elixirs and so on.
So this was crucial.
Now here is a,
is a lab that could easily be
for an owl chemical laboratory,
but in fact it's an early chemical
laboratory. And I'll show it to you here.
It's this book.
It's this picture here from 1777 from a
book about air and fire and it reports
the discovery of a new element in
this book and it's by Carl Ville Helm,
Shayla in, uh, who is in a, uh,
in Uppsala, whoops, a law in Sweden.
What do you think,
what do you think you discovered with
light and fire or propriety with,
with air and fire loof to
employer. Uh Huh. We'll see.
Okay.
So that's his laboratory shale is
laboratory or at least some artist's
impression of it. And here he is. He's,
he's before the chemical revolution,
but he's an important precedent as
you'll see to the chemical revolution.
He was a, as my practice, a pharmacist,
but he spent most of his time doing
what is really chemical research.
Here's a picture of a
stamp, a Swedish stamp, a,
of showing shale, except it's not. Shayla,
turns out the costume is where I wouldn't
have been developed until 40 years
after Shayla died.
Okay.
But he purified organic compounds that
weren't easy to purify in particular
carboxylic acids.
So he got an acid from
that he called lactic acid,
which we now know has that structure.
Where did he get it from? Sour milk.
Okay.
And he got,
so here's the his paper about that on
milk and it's acid right from 1780 so he
purified these acids as salts
that he could crystallize.
That was the method of
purifying. So here's, here's
several reports in that paper.
Item seven, bismuth, cobalt,
antimony, tin, mercury,
silver and gold were attacked by
lactic acid either by digestion.
That's a just sitting there under it
or by boiling after standing over 10,
the acid caused the black precipitate
to form in a solution of gold in aqua
regia. Right? So this is
not mysterious writing,
right? It's talking in language
that we can understand.
Even though it's translated from German,
iron and zinc were dissolved with
a formation of flammable air.
What do you suppose he reacted?
Acid with zinc and he got flammable air.
What do you suppose that
was? Hydrogen, right?
The iron solution was brown
and gave no crystallization,
but the zinc solution crystallizes.
Why was that important?
Because he could purify it if it
crystallized, get just that salt. Right?
So that's how he got pure samples
of acids, right? With copper,
our solution first took on a blue
color than green. Finally, dark blue,
but did not crystallize,
unfortunately,
and 10 led dissolved after
several days of digestion,
the solution acquired a sweet tart taste,
but did not crystallize,
right?
So what do you do when you
don't have IIR and Nmr, right?
Sure.
So we tasted all these things cyanide to,
okay, so we've got citric
acid. Where did you get that?
From? Lemons. Okay. And he got uric acid.
Obvious.
He got tartaric acid.
That's a little tartaric
acid turned his discovery.
It turns out to be one of the single,
probably the single most important,
maybe the second. Now, probably the most
important compound in the 19th century,
as you'll see. Okay?
That comes from Tartar,
which is the deposit or the inside of
wine casks after you fermented wine.
Okay?
Benzoic acid came from gum benzoin
product to the near of the Far East.
Okay. And oxalic acid. Where
do you think that came from?
It came from rhubarb.
Now why oxalic?
Why oxy?
Oxy means sharp.
So what the sharp have to
do with it with rhubarb.
Yeah. So you know, oxy is
as a root, meaning sharp.
A oxymoron doesn't mean a stupid ox.
What it means is sharp
and Moron means doll.
So it's a sharp dullness is an oxymoron.
It's a self contradictory word,
right?
So what's sharp about rhubarb?
It's taste.
It tastes acidic.
In fact,
the word acidic comes from the Latin us
deduce which comes from Acre to be sour,
which comes from the root [inaudible]
which means sharp. So it's the same thing.
Acid and oxy.
Okay,
so look at all these
things they have what?
The carb oxalate group, which
makes them acidic. Right?
And we know why it makes it a city.
This is review from last time, right?
This function room,
it's not a carbon eel alcohol,
it's a carboxylic acid.
The high homo is stabilized in the acid,
but it's even more
stabilized when it's an anti.
And cause you have a higher homo.
So it changes the acidity,
the ease of the Association of h
plus by a factor of 10 to the 11th.
Right. Which depends on the energy
difference between those two.
So if you're more stabilized,
the anti on product,
then you stabilize the starting material,
then you shift the reaction toward
product here by 10 to the 11th big change.
Okay. But actually there's more
to it than just that resonance.
Just that Homo Lumo interaction.
There's a thing called inductive
effects that we'll talk about later on,
but a large part of it is due to that.
Okay.
But you notice there's one exception here.
Uric acid doesn't have a
carboxylic group in it.
So there's what it has and it,
uh,
notice that it has an unshared
pair on nitrogen like an amid.
It's stabilized by a carbon eel. In
fact, it's stabilized by two carbon eels,
two adjacent lumos to stabilize
it. Now, if that were just stable,
it wouldn't be a reason to loot to, to
get rid of it. She'll lose a proton.
But the anti and that you get if you lose
the proton from nitrogen has a higher
homo.
So it's even more stabilized.
The same trick is in carboxylic acid,
but even more so as you'll see here that
pka of this compound is 5.8 it's pretty
acidic,
right?
But a normal amine like ammonia losing
of Proton has a pka of 38 right?
So this is 32 powers of 10 helped out
because it has such a high homo on the
nitrogen and two Carbonells
to stabilize it, okay?
So uric acid is in is
indeed in acid light car,
very light carboxylic acids, okay? Now,
Shayla not only did these organic acid,
he also discovered or co-discovered
seven elements there are listed here
according to what row
of the periodic table.
They're in a notice down at the
bottom here you have tungsten,
right? Tungsten comes from
Swedish, he was Swedish.
It's tongue Stan heavy
stone being weighed down.
It's got lots of protons and neutrons
and is very, very dense, right?
So it's heavy. The stone that
comes from our very heavy, right?
But by contrast, these up
here are gases. And in fact,
that's what got the 19th
century chemistry going.
That's what launched
the chemical revolution,
was the ability to work with gases
because they were to be a gas,
something has to be a small molecule and
therefore simple or at least relatively
simple.
So you had to start with simple things
before you could get to complex ones like
salycilic acid in terms of understanding.
Now,
Shayla in 1771 had heated silver carbonate
and he found that he got CO2 out.
I mean, he didn't know it was co two
that again, the gas came out okay.
And if you heat it that still
more greater than 340 Celsius,
then you get silver and oxygen
comes out from silver oxide.
This gas, this foyer lift, right?
Fire Air. That's what
the book is about. Okay,
so he wrote,
he wrote the book,
but the book starts as I'll show you here.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
There we go.
The book starts with an
introduction, uh, uh, forbearing, uh,
by which is translated
that says from Swedish.
And let's see where it says here.
And it's by Torbert and
Bergman written in 1777 this,
he had this book written for two years
waiting for this preface to come.
Bergman was a busy guy,
right.
And during the time that
this book was Sitting Ready,
the manuscript is ready to be,
was sitting ready to be printed.
Priestly in England discovered oxygen.
So this book came out after priestly,
but there's no doubt that that uh,
that Shayla had discovered it earlier is
lab books from 1771 show it and here in
1774 his,
his,
his draft of a letter that he wrote to,
to France and it begins here,
actually begins with a couple of words
on the previous sheet, but it says,
since I have no large burning glass,
I beg you to try with yours,
because he had to do this.
He didn't things in an oven,
really high temperature,
which was hard to do.
But if you could,
if you could do it with a focus
light of the sun to heat it,
then it would be much more practical.
And in France,
they had such a big magnifying glass
that would allow us to do it. But
that letter, although it was sent,
was never answered. And you know
who it was sent to? Presumably
Lavoie Zaa the founder of the chemical
revolution and another discover of oxygen.
Okay? Okay. So now we're going to talk
about Lavoie Zia who was re, you know,
it wasn't a perfect person, but
he was really very, very good.
Okay?
Now the chemical revolution began.
You can say it started in 1789.
That chemical revolution,
and that's not the only revolution
that started in France in 1789. Right?
You know what?
This is what it's the
tennis court oath when the,
when the, uh, the legislators,
so to say, gathered to, uh, to,
uh, say that they wouldn't disband until
the king granted them certain things.
And you know what that led to in 1789,
the only guy that didn't
degree was this guy here.
He's the only one that didn't
sign it. But at any rate, it's,
uh,
it was radical.
Now there's an Indo European root word
that's the root of many words called were
out. And it gives words in all sorts
of languages. Like it means root.
Okay.
And vortal in German means root and
[inaudible] Ward like St John's wort is a
root licorice. Glucose rise, a Greek,
the rices is root. Okay,
sweet root. It means, okay.
Race Rot in Italian is,
is the root of your, of your being, right?
Rutabaga
radix and in Latin. And you know,
lots of words come from radix,
like radish is a root or eradicate.
What does that mean?
It means to pull it out by the roots.
Okay.
Or radical.
Something that's radical is something
that goes right to the root.
Back to the very origin of something.
And that word used in that way.
If you look in the Oxford
English dictionary,
it was used in math coined in
mathematics in the 16th century.
The root of a number is its origin,
right?
If you take the square root of a
number and multiply it by itself,
you get the number. So it's the root
of the number, the radical right.
Or in politics that was used
in 18th century in England
and in chemistry in 18th
century in France. They idea of radical
is the root of things began to be used,
which we'll see. Okay, so 1787,
a radical was introduced as a political
term according to the Oxford English
dictionary by Ajay, Jeb, whoever
he was presumably a politician.
Or in 1787, there was this radical
document. We the people, right?
But that same year, 1787, uh,
radical was introduced as a
chemical term by Louis Bear.
Narky toned more Volvo.
And it was in the,
in the context of developing
nomenclature for chemistry.
So he, together with bare metal lay and
[inaudible] developed a new method for
nomenclature in chemistry.
And here's a book.
This is not the original French, but it's
the first English translation, which is,
he comes from the,
uh,
Yale University library
back when it's from a 1788.
Okay.
So a method of chemical
nomenclature by Gaytonia Marvo,
Lavoie, Z, a bear to delay in four quad.
So the fourth author
of this new method of,
of chemical nomenclature is Lavoie z.
So there's Lavoie Zia with his
wife. This is part of, uh, of uh,
enormous picture that's
in the metropolitan. Uh,
and it was commissioned by Lavoie Zay
and his wife who hired a Jacques Louis
Daveed to paint it and they paid 7,000
pounds to the artists to paint it,
which is equivalent of $300,000.
Today. They were quite well to do,
they had an income of the order of
$1 million a year or the equivalent,
it depends on how you, how you translate
numbers. Of course it's hard. Uh,
so here he is at the age of 45 and
1789 and he's working on drafting.
So he,
so you know,
these guys when they had their portraits
painted always put something important
in it. So what did he
choose to have? He chose,
chose to be working on a manuscript
and the manuscript is working on,
is the manuscript of this
book right from 1789.
It's called cut de la Frontera.
Does she meet the uh, the uh,
elementary treatise on
chemistry and the other stuff?
He put it in the picture are the,
is the equipment, uh, there is, uh,
is the equipment he used.
So,
so here you see various equipment
from one of the plates and the,
at the end of the book, and you can see
these items in the picture. There's that,
that bell jar.
There's that device.
There's that big, uh, 16 pint,
a flask with a brass fitting on it.
Uh,
there's that valve that's on that you
attached to the bottom of the flask and
over here as a portfolio and the portfolio
is says down in the corner of Poles.
Love was the AA school seat. That means
this was drawn by polls. Lavoie Zia,
who is his wife,
she was his assistant in the laboratory,
kept all the notebooks, read English for
him because he couldn't read English.
So we had to do anything with
priestly. She would read it to him. Uh,
but she drew all these things.
She studied with Davita drawing
in order to be able to do this.
Uh, okay. She drew this, this, uh,
she painted this portrait of their
family friend. Who's that? Yeah,
Benjamin Franklin. I showed
you that picture earlier,
said we'd refer to it again.
So this is that,
that particular plate in the book and
it relates to weighing a gas know,
turn out that the most important thing
for Lavoie Oza and for the whole 19th
century,
all this development that led to bonds
and their arrangement weighing was the
key thing. But how do you weigh
a gas? So you need gasses.
So they're simple enough to deal
with and easy to purify, right?
But you need to weigh them. So
how can you weigh a gas? Well,
you can collect a gas as shown in this
picture by generated it in this a retort
g and it comes in at bubbles up
displacing water or mercury off most often
mercury from a bell jar. You've done
this kind of thing. Some of you,
but you can see how it would work is
that bubbles up, the mercury comes down.
Okay,
so now you have the gas.
Now we'll shift attention down to the
bottom right here and see how this works.
So we have, uh, this
bell jar on the bottom,
which is filled with valves on the top
is filled with mercury and it's in a pool
of mercury.
And then this big 16
pint flask is evacuated.
You used one of these pumps,
remember a hundred years before this hook
or a hundred and 130 years before this
hooked,
made a great vacuum pump for Boyle.
Boyle is the only person on the front
of the building older than Lavoie
[inaudible].
Right?
And that was dealing with gases and
Boyle's law out pressure and volume relate
to one another. Okay. So anyhow, uh,
he, he could evacuate that with a pump,
then seal it off,
turn the valves off and he's got mercury
in that thing and now he puts a tip
underneath it and generates gas
and it bubbles up and fills the,
uh,
this container with the gas and it's
sitting in a mercury pool so that it's not
communicating with the atmosphere other
than through the pressure through the
mercury pool. Okay. So
now he opens the valves.
So the vacuum starts sucking up the
mercury that is pulling the area up to a
certain point, right? Then the
mercury stops rising. Okay.
And now at this point,
you know that the pressure of that gas
is atmospheric pressure less whatever the
height of the Mercury column is,
right? That's how a barometer works.
So he knows how much gas,
what volume of gas at uh,
he has in a, he knows the, he,
he filled it with water first and
waited to see what its volume was.
Now he knows the volume,
he knows the pressure.
So he knows how much gas there would
be at atmospheric pressure. Right?
And now of course, he just turns
off these things unscrews one,
uh,
the thing on top and ways it and sees how
much heavier it is than it was when it
was evacuated. And that's how much the
airways, and he knows how much volume,
how much pressure. So he knows how
much, whatever gas he collected wade,
so he could weigh a
gas. Pretty Clever, Huh?
Okay. Here he is working with
one of these bell jars. Now.
Uh, he, he, these bell jars were filled
with mercury. I don't know if you've,
uh,
would you help me out Wilson,
lift this up and show it to the class,
but don't lift it high.
Hold it above the thing. Did
it surprise you? Yeah, it's a,
he said it surprised him. And you can
come up afterwards if you want to.
It'd be surprised yourself
by lifting this up,
but keep it over this because people
are so panicked about mercury nowadays.
I hear on the way over to class,
while I was bringing this,
I heard there's a new law in the,
in the European Union that it's going
to be illegal to transport mercury over
international borders. Go figure. Anyhow,
there's Lavoie Z. I do it and experiment
with this big thing of mercury, right?
He must've been a stout person.
Okay.
This is him and his library with Madame
La Boissiere taking his dictation as he
does his experiments.
Okay.
So here's the Tata La Montera to
she me and I'll show you the, this,
this actually is a facsimile,
not the real thing. Uh,
but here's the title page.
The first volume.
Okay.
So you could look at that if you want to.
And at the end,
I'll just note here in the s at the end
of the second volume or all of these
pages, which are, uh,
devices like here's this is
the one we just looked at.
Okay. So if you want to look at them, feel
free. Don't handle the other one though.
It's real. Okay. Uh,
so elementary treatise of
chemistry presented in a new order.
This is the revolution according to
modern discoveries with figures as I just
showed you.
And 1789 is the date the same
as the French revolution.
Okay?
Okay. You notice he's a member
of all different academies,
including Philadelphia.
Why in the world would he have been
a member of the Scientific Academy of
Philadelphia? You never went
there, right? It's Powell. Okay.
1789.
So it has the most wonderful
introduction called d score.
[inaudible] and he says,
I hit my only object
when I began this work,
or I had no other object when
I began the following work.
Then to extend and explain
more fully the memoir,
which I read at the public meeting, the
Academy of Science in the month of April,
1787 remember when radical
was introduced and so on,
on the necessity of reforming and
completing the nomenclature of chemistry.
So that's all he was trying to do was
get a proper nomenclature that would be
useful in contrast all this,
uh, al chemical nonsense. Okay.
While engaged in this
employment, I perceived better
than I had ever done before.
The justice of the
following maxims of the RBA,
the cardiac in his system of
logic and some other work.
So this is what [inaudible] said.
We think only through the medium of words,
why languages are true analytical methods,
Algebra,
which is adapted to its purpose in
every species of expression in the most
simple, most exact and best manner
possible. Is it the same time,
a language and an analytical method?
The Art of reasoning is nothing
more than language well arranged.
So Lavoie Z,
he goes on to say this,
while I thought myself employed
only informing a nomenclature,
and while I proposed to myself nothing
more than to improve the chemical
language.
My work transformed itself by degrees
without my being able to prevent it into a
treatise upon the elements of chemistry.
So in the process of
reforming the language,
he reformed the whole
understanding of the science.
The impossibility of separating
nomenclature of a science from the science
itself is owing to this that every branch
of physical science must consist of
three things,
the series of facts,
which are the object of the science,
the ideas which represent these facts
and the words by which the ideas are
expressed.
Like three impressions of the same seal.
The word ought to produce the idea and
the idea to be a picture of the fact.
So all of these things have
to be harmonious, right?
Three impressions of the same seal.
And as ideas are preserved and
communicated by means of words,
it necessarily follows that we cannot
improve the language of any science
without at the same time improving
the science itself. Neither can we.
On the other hand,
improve a science without improving the
language or nomenclature which belongs
to it. However certain the
facts of any science may be.
However, just the ideas we may
have formed of these facts,
we can only communicate false impressions
to others while we want words by which
these may be properly expressed,
right?
So clarity as opposed to obscurity was
his goal as opposed to Newton or the
alchemists, right? Facts,
ideas and words and they all have to tie
into one another as impressions of the
same seal.
Okay,
so he presented things as he
and advertised in the new order,
very different from any book on
chemistry that had been written before.
First was doctrine. That is the
theory, the first part of the book,
which is a two volume books of almost
all of the first of about two thirds I
think, or the first volume or
doctrine and then nomenclature.
That's what he had set out to
do. And finally, operations,
how you can actually repeat this stuff
for yourself, what devices you need.
Of course,
he was very wealthy and could employ
people to manufacture all these equipment,
all the equipment he needed.
Not everybody could do that,
but he showed exactly how
it was done and gave great.
It's easy to understand
exactly what he did. Now,
one of the first things he turned his
attention to was elements. He says,
if by the name elements,
we mean to designate the
simple indivisible molecules.
Molecule just means little thing,
right? That make up substances.
It is probable. We do not know what
they are. They're just too small,
right?
But if on the contrary,
we associate with the name of elements
or the principles of substances,
the idea of the furthest stage two,
which analysis can reach all substances
that we have so far found no means to
decompose our elements for us.
They behave with respect to us like
simple substances. So it's an operational,
not a philosophical definition of element.
If you can't break it apart, consider it
an element until you can break it apart.
We have elements here that chemical
elements are they elements according to Po
two Lavoie CA's definition.
Like here we see a Sirium,
Presdo, Demian, neodymium,
promethium, Samarium, Europium Gadolinium.
Are they elements according to Lavoie?
CA, why not? You can
break them apart into new,
into nuclei and electrons.
The nuclei you could break apart into
protons and neutrons and the break these
things apart into corks and so on.
But for Lavoie,
Zia or for chemists, those are elements
cause you don't break them apart. Okay?
So here's a table of simple substances
in the first English translation of the,
of the Titanium Ontario does she meet?
So here's a table of the elements.
Simple substances belonging
to all the kingdoms of nature,
which may be considered
as the elements of bodies.
So what are the first two elements,
things that you can't break apart?
Light and heat are the first two elements,
which we don't see at men.
Chef's table,
right?
Because they're fundamentally different
from the other elements because they
don't have any weight.
You can weigh a gas,
but you can't weigh light and
you can't wait heat. Okay?
So he gives new names to these things.
Light and caloric.
And what the old name was.
Light used to be called light too.
But in this new system,
he's going to keep the old name or Caluori
he's going to use for what used to be
called heat or the principal or element
of heat or fire or igneous fluid or the
matter of fire heat.
Those were terms people had used before,
but he's going to call them caloric.
Okay?
Now if you have caloric,
you must be able to measure it.
If you can't weigh at what you can do,
you can use a calorimeter to measure it.
And this is the calorimeter manufactured
and used by Lavoie Zaa and also Laplas
a younger man who was his colleague
who became a great mathematician,
as you probably know. So
here's the thing, it's big.
That's a three foot rule,
right?
So this thing stood this high off the
table, right? Okay. Now here's what it is.
There's a lamp that's going to make fire.
There's oil in the well of the lamp,
and that's you're going to measure how
much heat you get out of burning that oil.
So you put it inside this bucket and
you put the bucket in this Mesh Cage and
put the lid on.
Then you put that cage and it's
lit up into this can. Okay.
And now you light the flame in there.
You want to measure how much heat it
gives. How do you measure the heat?
What you do is surrounded by melting ice.
So the heat will melt the ice.
Now there's going to be a problem.
The obviously the more heat,
the more ice you melt.
But that's not the only
place heat's coming from.
Where else will it come from
to melt the ice from outside?
So this is where the thing is clever.
So there's another can outside that can,
and you fill it with ice,
which is an insulator for the inside.
So no heat comes from the eye.
Any heat that comes from the outside melts
the outside eyes, not the inside eyes.
Only the flame will melt the inside eyes.
Okay?
And notice that the lids also
are covered with ice too.
So it's completely surrounded by I
ice and then buy another layer of ice.
So it's the flame burns, Burns,
Burns, Burns, and you feel water.
Water comes up as they
melted both of them.
And then you put that thing underneath
and turn the tab to tap and see how much
water was melted only by the flame.
Right.
And that measures how much
heat? Pretty Clever, Huh?
Okay. So that was, that's a fact.
Is measuring how much heat there is.
But analysis in general,
is it, this is from uh,
the Oxford English dictionary,
which Yale has a subscription to so
you can look up words to your heart's
content. It's a lot of fun. This,
this year is the 80th anniversary
of the Oxford English dictionary.
There was a symposium down down the hill
sponsored by the library with including,
uh, uh, the guy that wrote
the professor and the madman.
Has Anyone read that book about
the Oxford English dictionary?
It's a wonderful short book. And the
madman was a Yale graduate. It's really,
it's interesting story.
And the other guy was one who,
who read the Oxford English dictionary
cover to cover 20 volumes within one
year. He wrote a book about that during
the last year. It was a fun thing.
But anyhow, this is, it's fun to look up
things in the Oxford English dictionary.
And here's analysis.
So you see it comes from Ana and uh,
I think it's at least 18,
but I can get some help on that.
Louie, Louie and okay. Anyhow,
but it means to loose according
to the Oxford English there.
So it's to loose back. So it takes to
take things apart as the sense of it.
And generally it's the resolution or
breaking up of anything complex into its
various simple elements.
So you can analyze a pat
a passage and literature.
Okay. Uh, it's the opposite of synthesis.
Okay. Uh, it,
the exact determination of the elements
or components of anything complex,
specifically in chemistry,
the resolution of a chemical compound
into it's proximate or ultimate elements.
Now, proximate and ultimate,
what does that mean?
You can see down in the historical uses
of it what proximate and ultimate mean.
1791 the same time.
1789 remembers of,
tried to Montair said
the quantity of charcoal,
which something yields by analysis.
So you find out how much charcoal isn't
it? That's the word we've now say carbon,
right? So that's elemental
analysis. That's ultimate analysis.
Take things all apart to the chemical
elements, see how much of each one.
But there's also this thing
called proximate analysis,
which you can see from
this quote in 1831 sugar,
starch and gum are proximate principles.
And these we obtained
by proximate analysis.
So you can take some food stuff
and see what percentage of protein,
what percentage of sugar, what percentage
of this, that, and the other thing.
So what you read on a candy
bar or something like that.
That's proximate analysis, not
elemental, not ultimate analysis.
So both kinds are important in
Lovaza is work as we'll see.
Uh, okay, so we looked
at the light and caloric.
Now let's look at a few of these
elements. The ultimate elements here. Uh,
we have the fact,
the theory and the word for these things.
So how about [inaudible],
why is that word?
That's the French name for, uh, French.
Still call nitrogen as a,
and in this English translation,
it was called that in 1790 or 91.
Okay.
Where does that word come from?
What does the prefix a mean
without and how about Zo? That's
great. We have somebody taking Greek
without life.
In what sense is that inappropriate name?
A meaningful name for nitrogen.
Alex,
what kind of tests?
Yeah,
if you put a mouse
in an atmosphere of
nitrogen, it's Aza. Alright,
so that's what the name meant. So
he used, it used to be called flow,
just dicated air or gas or
Memphis or the base of Memphis.
This right?
Aza is the name that Lavasa
decides to use for it or hydro.
Jan,
how about it help us out?
Nope.
Pardon me.
Water.
What about water? Hydro
is water. What's Gen?
It makes water, right?
So if you burn hydrogen,
you generate water,
right? So Hydro Jen. Okay.
How about oxygen?
What does it generate?
Yeah,
acid.
Sourness.
So oxygen is the element that generates
sourness, that generates acid.
And that is the key element in Lavoie.
Ca's theory,
the oxygen theory of combustion.
Okay,
so oxygen plus a base or radical,
right?
So these two terms meant the
same thing. The Lavoie, ca,
the fundamental radical, the
root of some substance, right?
And you reacted with oxygen.
And it makes the stuff into an acid.
Can you think of an example of an
element that you react with oxygen?
It becomes an acid. Well,
let's just look at his table.
Sulfur.
You burn it and it becomes
sulfuric acid or sulfuric acid,
right? Phosphorus.
Janet's phosphoric acid.
Carbon generates carbonic acid.
Muriatic radical,
which we don't know, haven't
discovered the periodic radical yet,
the base of that acid. But if you
burn it and combine it with oxygen,
you get muriatic acid.
Does anybody know what Muriatic acid is?
Hydrochloric acid, how much
oxygen is in it? None, right?
But that was the theory, right? That you
take a base, you reacted with oxygen,
you get an acid. So there must
have been a muriatic radical,
okay. Unfortunately, that
part of it was wrong.
The same for Florick at radical,
okay.
But then there were also come pound
radicals, radicals that were not,
that were only proximate,
not ultimate right.
Radicals that had several
other elements in them, right?
And here were some of those like, uh, uh,
a list of those radicals with the names
that Lavoie ca decided to use for them.
And many of them,
all the ones indicated by an air or
ones that Shayla had already discovered.
Right? Like Tar Tarik, citric
oxalic, Benzoic, lactic.
Lithic acid was another one
that I didn't mention before,
which comes from stones. See,
it's for me, urinary calculus.
Okay. So those were compound
radicals. And that's, uh,
the end of today's lecture.